Howard Stern Show Tracy Morgan old
friend of the show on many many times we
all know he had a horrible accident but
he's back he's back and Bette let me
look at you
let me look at you I mean look at you
great look at you he's the same hey man
you ready you're ready to bang Robin I
know you're fine my man how long I love
you Howard my brother you are good yeah
sure good you look good I mean I would
say this is the thinnest I've got a
letter
now I got to let oh yes when I first
came home from the hospital I know and I
and I said oh man I I didn't know how to
reach and I didn't know what to do I was
so upset about this accident and I
called Jimmy Kimmel go well you you know
Tracy better than I do get it kid I was
trying to reach out you know the Gotti
family the Colombo family and I try to
reach out did they all treat our Obama
call to come with a keep me back not to
a big aughh member traicee with the
people who didn't reach out who perhaps
your mother's is that right chicks I had
sex with didn't take my socks off yeah
you're saying in a life-threatening
situation there are women who are so
angry with you they won't wake up he was
so bad to them looking like [ __ ] him my
oh my god
getting this out there Oh for the most
part I feel like I tapped into something
man
lot of love and goodwill I'd get for me
yeah I'm tapped into it
I always show upset and I couldn't get
in touch with you and I felt like listen
I didn't want her talking to nobody man
I wasn't in the state of mind for that
you know how to spell my name I could
barely talk and my feet I was in a
wheelchair for six months but my feet
like this man managed I wasn't ready for
none of that you don't know what time I
me and my wife went to the mall
and I freaked out cuz people started
coming around me he's like looking at me
like like they saw ghosts because it was
in the media that I was gay right and no
I was Tracey the thing that freaked me
out the most that I read and tell me
freaked you out okay after you came out
of your coma you were in a coma for like
almost eight days am i correct yeah
uh-huh yet when you open your eyes you
could not see you were blind for a day
for five days did you did they think
that maybe your vision wouldn't even
come back no they don't know they didn't
know these are the neurons and your
brains that are destroyed right well it
takes time to heal they still heal and
now what it what are the injured like
how did you how does your sight get
knocked out of you in other words I
couldn't even answer these questions
because you were a doctor doctor right
you know I just know that my wife said
um you know she had she we were our way
on the Turnpike exit eight is where it
happened
right there and on you went back you
could get some clothes and the nurse
Laura stayed in there with me every day
all day she sat in the room with me
every day all day and when I first came
off the helicopter she doesn't wanna cut
my bloody clothes off of me Wow so she
stayed with me she stayed with me so my
wife went back home to get some clothes
because they had a hotel across the
street and um she said she was getting
close and then the phone rang and nurses
said he's up and he asked for you so she
just rushed back to the hospital with my
son and I was blind but I touching her
face I was like I know such enough face
so they don't even know when you come
out of a coma they don't even know if
you'll get your sight back at all right
but
so I don't remember none of that that
would be the freakiest thing - because
me obviously oh my god I can't see right
now and I don't know what hit me because
but from what I read you say you don't
even remember the accident you don't
remember any of the details nor do you
want to god yeah you were gone but do
you want to know why you're in the
hospital what what happened I asked my
wife why my hair yeah I didn't find out
Jimmy was going to two weeks later
because they didn't want to upset you at
that point if you in are in the rumors
of what I heard they keep you in over
talk room now so you don't stimulate
your brain so - swelling go down and the
thing I just feel fortunate you doctor
you'll bless no I will bless when I was
born we all are blessed no you were
blessed because doctors gave you less
than a 2% chance of living I mean this
is the wrong area second chance
he did you said that when you were
unconscious and first of all if the
thing is is I'm really curious and I
think it's to talk about it I understand
talk about it belamis him did you feel
any I know after you wake up you're in
pain but when when you come that close
to death and the actual incident happens
do you feel any pain whatsoever because
that always freaks me out like my wife
said that I choked all the time to try
to get out the bed they were and I
didn't even know my my femur was
pulverized
I got a titanium rod in my leg for life
for my knee to my head mm-hmm but with
those pins they not do trust me I got
the x-rays at my house laughs um I was
bad and just the trauma to my head was
kind of bad and you know I broke every
bone in my face said my face was this
big Wow
she was really scared you don't feel any
pain when the actual accident happens
like you'd like I you know what I want
to know that like if I fell out of a
building or you don't feel any I did I
don't remember none of it your brain
shuts down that's what the brain does it
goes to the protection mode Tracy we
don't want to remember it Tracy everyone
wants to know when did you jerk off for
the first time oh my god it happened
I was going on in the hospital oh you
relish yeah all I do is mess to me I
think I did like it only money I've got
a constraint is I really can is that
true when you come back close to death I
woke up one morning and my dick was
dialing I won one girl the nurse my
heart machine started going off one day
the nurses on the floor they started
running in my room and they opened the
door I was in their beat mother is that
really true yeah it's true
but but I'm gonna cover when you're in
that bed of [ __ ] and I imagine the pain
is tremendous when your leg is all
[ __ ] up and everything yeah got
nothing to do a beating all right eating
off relaxes you can beat all through
pain and all that really but when you're
in a hospital aren't you afraid to be
afraid of what ain't afraid that's my
fantasy around Danny Boy did you sleep
we don't get on board did you say that
your physical therapist then you had a
great team oh my god she had a gun
before
I know but you oh my god when she's a
soldier
Glenda cool yeah did God she was six one
you guys wanna hear big titty you're so
they were real cuz he shagged a little
bit they were real you said you
sterilized big saggy titties useful baby
titty you said yeah Oh Lady titty
nipples big nipple lady kid like ten
times you've said that your therapist
look like a young Raquel Welch
I'm yes that's dangerous around of a
license wow the young black girl from
all of me Abner yeah be serious about
something that I I do take seriously
because what there are very few people I
know and God bless you Tracy I love you
I want it first of all I want to be
serious for one second I love you and I
want you to know I was so [ __ ]
worried about you because you know at
first there was like how serious is this
and when I got word from a couple of
people who are in the inside they said
man this is the real deal I mean he
might go how's God and then I didn't
hear from anybody for a while and I kept
calling people and I tried reaching
to you and of course you know listen you
had your hands full but I I really I'm
just so happy you're with us and you
know I've always been so I love you and
you've been such a good friend to the
show I want you to know that and I thank
God you here thank God right yeah and I
was so upset and I you know you're just
such a funny guy in uni and you're such
an upbeat kind of guy I remember sitting
with you at a knick game and just when
you were carrying on like a lunatic I
went this guy isn't doing this to get
paid right now he's just let me tell you
something man is gonna take more 18
wheels get that away from me yeah I'm
still I do which is hard to be funny
again though because I was worried I had
other things on my mind it was beyond
show business at the beginning I'm right
he's beyond show he was life and death I
was looking at my daughter my daughter
was young she was 10 months old and
happy right now
tweet now my wife is young my wife 80th
my sons and I was worried I didn't know
yeah I being in the bathroom in the
morning and Burghley glad you start
running down my face yeah so you worry
about things like that and then I didn't
I you know I was so depressed cuz I just
was seeing everybody and I was getting
better because I was working hard with
the therapist and the speech therapist
and he's a beautiful ladies I love
everybody that that saved my life
I met I did a show in New Brunswick a
couple of months ago and Laura stepmom
and I did a show for the hospital
because it was right across the street
at that theta uh-huh and 200 people they
stayed gave me a standing ovation at the
end and I asked everybody to please
stand up if you were in that hospital
and 200 people stood up I said give them
the standing ovation right first your
hair shows the first responder he's 23
you're white too young boy I was the one
that pulled me out the van at night Wow
I met him he sat right next to me he's
been seeing a doctor for two years
his mother whispered in my ear he was
covered from head to toe your blood Wow
he said it when they take you out of in
shots of my man Todd I was driving that
night and Todd who was driving time hi
when I'm gonna smash yeah I mean even
even the way they doctors know how to
remove
move you from a terrible accident scene
because they could [ __ ] you up even more
if they don't do it just right am i
correct everybody was a professional
around you oh it was the first one as he
thought yes the Marty was in the article
I was in he was in a coma with me right
and Jeff still just up Jeff my sister
yeah male he was in a coma - and I asked
for I knew when I was ready to come back
cuz there ladies - forgiveness yeah I
had to start with myself because I asked
everybody to be there that night
ya know you you you just go over my talk
in other words you felt guilty because
you were and of course you weren't but I
understand it you're going to do a show
and you said to your pals hey come with
me even invited your wife to come no no
no she was it I invite her right my
daughter was two months old she was he
was teated right and so she had a to
fake so I told my wife the night before
don't come sail your bays stay here
thinking she's with me the whole talk
Hana babies with me to hold shorts after
that night wow that's my trauma that's
my Vietnam that I live with and struggle
with every day when I first came over
back why is that a struggle because I
will keep them like this and my wife
will fight me or you can't do this what
should we you were hugging your wife her
no was it good I didn't want them go
nowhere
I want to win me because what happened
and you wanted to watch our little care
they got a live yeah yeah just sort of
supermarket don't go out going yeah so
so so when I was getting better yeah
that was getting bad but Tracey was
lucky that you said you know if it was
lucky let's say lucky to me I'm saying
wages in that world luck to me it was
fortunate that kill your wife stayed
home honest people in Atlantic City in
Vegas right for losers it was fortunate
that she stayed home that night right
and that's yeah yeah and and by my
daughter yes and you say you describe
guilt because the comedians and stuff
who were with you were there by your
invitation Jimmy Mac was my og I know
that was your guy your mentor og right
62 years old so he was the uncle that
another had when I was acting crazy he
will put me to the solemn talk to
Youngblood right pull your coat
Youngblood
he was a talented comedian himself yeah
he was one of my facilitators on tour
that night right yeah he had written a
joke for you and you said hey why don't
you come to the show so you can see me
wear this joke it worked it worked
what was the joke rose Briggs I forget
it was a it was when on buzzer gotta own
the Clippers yeah Oh Donald sterling dr.
Lee yeah yeah it was I forgot to Jimmy
you written you a joke about Donald
sterling and you said hey let's go work
this joke see the door to see if it
flies that's what we're doing yeah what
were you in a limo or were you in one of
those big vans like it's Prince's the
big print if we wasn't in that we'd of
being squads like accordions because so
Sprint's or that's what I do was up a
year later I didn't know he was up for
28 hours I didn't know yeah yeah the guy
who was driving the Walmart truck well
you know um that's a real danger in our
country actually pointed out something I
mean a lot of trouble usin all those
things cell phone use only distraction
while you're driving a piece of iron
like that yeah and a lot of truck
drivers are up for a tremendous amount
of hours can't do that now
it costs my good man is life you can't
do you got a rest could you ever forgive
the driver could you ever say one day I
pray to God all the time right the
strength to do that right just the
strength I don't ask for nothing else
right just to strength my reward isn't
the wood you know I was more than money
and all of that it was justice for Jimmy
for all those involved yeah it was just
justice I was seeking yeah I wanted
justice for the families audience Jeff
they never did nothin to nobody right so
it's justice by the way speaking of I
know you can't talk about the amount of
money you received from Walmart and it's
irrelevant to me but I know there's a
lot of money uh you know it's a thing
the money though never can really make
up for this yeah Megan she's going
through when you wake up blind and you
were in a coma for all that time now
you've said yes yeah because I when I
think about my daughter now mmm going on
without me but a bit a disaster
you can't money can't fix that no I
think about Jimmy with the fun visa
on the phone that night just tell each
other jokes that's gone Danny lost his
life yeah but he promised me when he was
alive that he wouldn't leave me and I
believed them I know he up there with my
dad my grandmother nan now so my reward
is it monetary my reward is not in this
world my reward is where he walked me
into his kingdom and I see all of them
again yeah Tracy I'll treat people here
I'm good to people good to myself Tracy
your verse was important you're very
spiritual man do you you do believe that
when you were in the coma for eight days
you saw your father your father died
when you were nine I don't know if I was
in a coma in or out I just remember that
vision of your dad yeah dreaming good
whatever he had all green what'd he say
to you I'm not ready this year and I'm
not ready right no he said he's not
ready
oh he's not ready for me right and I
just was crying when you when you uh
wake up and you know suddenly you know
you're in the hospital you're you know
you can't walk you're right you can't
move you can't see remember those days
laying in the hospital bed Robin and
just looking out the window at night
just looking out the window
mmm I meant one particular night when it
was raining I was laying in the hospital
bed without toilet in the morning and I
just just looking out the window
do you I looked at this show during my
recovery a lot before we had and we did
yeah the fun we had a look at every
episode for a year over and over over
well you were afraid that you could
never get back to the Tracy that like we
knew like was there a doubt in your mind
that you might yeah you might not have
the ability to keep doing a little bit
yeah because no God ain't Indian giver I
just had to be in front of people but
when you can't walk and your memories
all [ __ ] up from the accident and you
can't speak you have to literally go
into years of like years of therapy
you're probably still in physical
therapy am I correct yeah yeah so you
have to learn how to walk again but is
the mental and emotional
I realized that that crash turned me
into an emotional wreck but the doctor
said you try to get him anybody out
there listening you try to get him by
truck doing that fat going that fast
eighty-five thousand pounds of frozen
food in the back watching the - - you
turn you into a rat and I had them my
wife and my dad had to calm me down like
we hear you hear just you funny just
calm down my wife said died when I first
was able to say things she said the
first thing I said to her I was Ben I
hear there's freedom beyond because I
wanted to get out loudly I said there's
freedom outside the doors you ever feel
bad like your favorite person I was
there was my business my business
manager Mark Landsman he didn't have his
business manager hat on right so friend
of mine right he took care of me my
family in there I bet I bet you realize
you're crazy I'm not more Glenn do so
much because oh no Kevin Lewis Kay my
publicist they friends of my zit way
beyond another word isn't it you saw
that they were true friends yeah
you learn who your friends are do you
feel guilty that like you say to your
wife don't worry you know I just want
you to go to Howard I'm sorry well I'm
sorry that you went to that Robin cuz
we're friends I consider us friends and
when you hurt when a friend of yours is
like hurt like that and I'm sorry well
you don't have to we understood I was
appraised I was afraid you would pissed
off at me or something I didn't know no
I mean because I figured well I'm gonna
write Tracy I'm gonna I didn't want you
to talk about the seatbelt thing though
cuz in the police reporter said they
didn't know if we had our zorg
and it didn't matter because if
somebody's doing that 65 miles per hour
seatbelt doesn't work it doesn't see
folks would have killed us possibly
right you don't know no does cut us
right in half didn't saved us was that
he woke up at the last second try to
turn left
that's what you done it and we started
rolling roll down right down a ditch and
while we were rolling while we were
rolling I figured God was floating in
the air and he looked at us cuz three of
us went into comas and one died
instantly
he said you you you stay here you come
with me okay that's what happened you
know I know I know before
with the accident it's all for me to
talk about this is very hard I intend to
just really I'm used to being funny
and but I noticed a different show right
now right cuz of what happened yeah what
happened no no let me time to be funny
that I understand that what about what
about your relationship with your mom
did anything change I know we've talked
many my mom went my mom came to see me
she did that night huh my brother my
sister and then my mom told TMZ that huh
my wife had an argument and my wife
wouldn't let us see me ah my wife is a
beautiful person
my wife is nothing like that my wife is
a very kind person kind natured person
yes so I don't know why my mom did that
I just don't know why you know you're
crazy it seems no matter on my deathbed
I don't know why she had enough to deal
with she had obtained month-old baby and
she's we were about to get married
hmm that set us back a year in change
Tracy married Naldo yeah because you
know you've said you've been very open
about the fact that you and your mom
don't talk and all that kind of stuff
and it's not good so I thought maybe
this accident would have the Royals
clothes that and instead she spoke to
TMZ and that [ __ ] you had up more well
you don't you don't want to take
cellphones and stuff and you know do
that don't do that no well people have
done that
oh my brows daughter and all of that
yeah well your mom didn't do that to you
no I would do that
no but you you resent the fact that she
spoke to TMZ about my wife about your
wife yeah yeah so it so that
relationship probably is just never
gonna be on track I guess you know who
knows
I don't know guy by truck right you're
fine yeah yeah and everything's good and
one day that'll even work itself out or
not yep
my whole family came to see me when I
came out to coma ah just to tell me he
loved me
yeah except for my grandmom you know
like every other old black woman on she
care about his education
I made it I'll survive she's a good now
you go back get your GED
I made something myself I was on 30 rock
she said if you had your GED you
terminal 60 rock so the thing that
inspired you to get out of the bed even
though you were wracked with pain you
couldn't walk my daughter it was
watching you 41 old daughter at the time
learn how to walk and you said I'm gonna
learn at home in my wheelchair and in my
wheelchair did you have to wear a diaper
were you like so were you able to go to
the bathroom when you had non big shots
to do that clean my bed when I saw
myself in the hospital I love you big
dudes is that the worst part of it like
he say I don't want to do baby was yeah
dignity was yeah but it was bigger than
that man I care about that you don't
think about donut that teach about that
yeah I I never know why care about that
mom Wow right I care about that's Betty
it's better what I'm going to I know but
I'm just like I am I wouldn't want
anybody doing anything for me I was
[ __ ] on yourself no what are you
okay kindergarten it was an accident
I had an accident oh boy so I buried my
underwear in my backyard
now no what about go back to the sex for
a second masturbation occurs ooh bashed
about first time yeah oh my god I came
when I was ready to go how long I felt
like I'm back in high school my dick got
hard like I would write school on how
big brick the dead Dick Tracy here
you've been through a horrible action
you have to learn how to walk again you
have to learn how to see again you have
to learn how to talk again right I mean
you're a guy who relies on talking as a
way of a narrative and they weren't sure
if you had brain damage they're still
not sure what the [ __ ] happened right
Yeah right you might have some brain
damage but I don't see any any
indication of it well you know you take
a bump like that on your head it's never
always the same yeah do you notice
differences yeah you do and what's up I
do I know when you do stand-up now I
mean it's hard for you stand arms yeah
timing right balance
you know things but I work I work hard
yeah I work hard I work on it you can
reroute all of that stuff is free then
that's what the brain yeah yeah totally
correct and rewrote but don't you think
you were able to reroute because you had
such drive to get back you in other
words you could retire now you have so
much so much money
the first respondent said to me good
when he first took me and he pulled me
out he was the first one to touch me he
said do you was covered in blood you use
up go on yeah the heat so then he had
some other guys pulling me out and he
said when we pulled you out you started
swinging so I'm thinking that's just
nerves he said why would you I said well
was a swinging like that
right he said you was fighting for your
life oh wow you were unconscious and yet
your arms were doing this involuntary
sort of responded kidney transplant I
got diabetes
I've been to a lot of wolves man I'm
ready I'm fighting now for Tracy let me
ask you something when you go through
something like what you went through
which very few people go through do in a
way do you take better care of yourself
now like are you watching your diabetes
are you being more careful on so my
diabetes man I gotta talk let me see
that pump oh look at that what is that
doing that come on man I got a monitor
man Wow
his blood sugar and get on my phone man
does that mean - does that mean that
you're taking there is I'm trying to
live man appreciate life more [ __ ] that
yeah
that means I'm trying to live are you
gonna try 9 I go to trick bag man right
I'm gonna say no Church will take you
right let me tell you something all the
good willing should I got going on now
Jamila dude did something you're robbing
attacked in this song yeah pretty yo is
overwhelming right there's some
beautiful in the last life yeah maybe I
gave Jesus some water okay Traci be
someone's [ __ ] maybe you wanted us
because yeah but I think I'm the one I
punch Judas in a [ __ ] [ __ ]
snap but crazy crazy isn't it true that
with all the goodwill you're getting
when you my dick got bigger - I did you
a gun no the head is more Bolger no the
head the head of your dick looks more
bulbous man when the therapist coming
came right I start going to my therapy
and boxer shorts yes I one day I had a
wardrobe malfunction
uh-uh they get popped out the golf of my
dick was grinning at up isn't it because
you lost weight that your dick appears
bigger honestly doing it really I got my
moves mediums I was not a virgin before
but now I was about eleven your dick was
nine and three counts down to my meat
cat I have to see that Monday because I
say well I should have given him
physical therapy when you therapist up
you describe a situation where you're
wearing boxer shorts you dick falls out
of your shorts and the therapist gasped
in other words was like oh my god yes
and so your dick got bigger
mr. pollution excuse me she said y'all
know she might be pregnant to Goose club
gunshot oh ah
I'll shoot the cabo Tracy you talk about
bug blow Tracy your homes gonna pull
down Tracy when you talk about goodwill
which you've had a lot of right but some
people are still [ __ ] faces right
because when you got out
and then you would drive for [ __ ] faces
I have some work question go ahead you
took that [ __ ] hit for me
mm-hmm now when you would you took that
hit for me Tracy when you were driving
you were driving you have a Lamborghini
it's a very beautiful car are you
driving it and some guy pulled up next
to you and started giving you some
[ __ ] right pull up next to me what
was on the sidewalk What did he say yeah
he just said I'm you know this is
[ __ ] you're just on Matt Lauer
crying now you got a fancy car this is
[ __ ]
and I parked the car and I approached
him and I asked him I said you two took
that hit for me hmm he would look at me
cuz now he's scared yeah I'm running my
[ __ ] bag now right let's see guy
yelled I said you took the [ __ ] for
me I'm on the streets near Cornell house
we looked and then I got closer and I
said so he shook his head no I said the
next time you ever seen me if God bless
you to see me again don't you ever say
[ __ ] about what I'm wearing when I'm
driving or what I'm saying I'm a [ __ ]
knock you out imma hurt you badly you
know Tracy it's so true because I just
got out the hospital I'm doing my thing
I'm living I'm trying to get my life
back
I'm trying to take my life back Tracy
and jigs are you a [ __ ] car that was
dying right you worried about a car and
I almost died Tracy it's so true
humanity yeah Tracy the lack of it from
him Tracy it's so true that some people
humans most people that come across
they'll get about what I'm driving when
I'm wearing Athens happy you yes happy
hour dogs that isn't it amazing most
people is it an amazing that sometimes
people get jealous of a guy who is you
gotta have the NLL but wait a second you
get people get jealous because in a way
you're getting all this attention and
they're people who don't get attention
and they want they want to put you down
for little wala comedy I've done it you
wanna pay attention to my accident right
I get it
that's why I be on low that's why stay
in the crib right looking for that
mm-hmm I'm looking for that man getting
this for that yeah you're right one of
the star norwalk Hollywood I achieve my
my legacy
have you become more reclusive as a
result of what people say I think
so yeah you spend most of your time I'd
rather be soothing of a soothing life I
listen to my music
you know Santa my Johnny Mathis and all
the things that seriously what do you
listen James Bob James you know taxi the
thing song for Johnny Mathis is one of
the most soothing taxi the theme song
from taxi yeah is that right but but
Johnny math is one of the most soothing
voices right the more voice yeah I just
I just relaxed my mind so my mind
doesn't keep going so get back to your
health for a second we'll get to the sex
in a minute but did you give up any
vices in other words did you when you
said hey I lived how would I been clean
for trophies you know that no but you
know what I mean and all of a sudden
you're thinner are you watching
everything you know my porn or my porno
I'm not talking about that I'm talking
about advice I'm just saying in other
words you're taking care of yourself in
a new way you're appreciating life you
know I did that before exit I see but I
don't know you look way healthier now
you look long when I came out I was when
I was 230 that's round one not 193
that's what I'm talking about now how
you losing the weight are you watching
everything you eat carbs yeah do you
work out hard mine I don't say the word
diet I just say change the lifestyle yes
and I was in the supermarket so mine
change the lifestyle starts there but I
put my car how many carbs I cut down on
the carbs all right shall now get the
Alex board I would cut down on the car
right that'll do it won't it yeah Ali
told me that long time ago I wasn't
really listening right and I said then
it dawned on me what he was saying and
it worked
different you know Alec has his hand in
the breadbasket when everyone's a good
coffee cake last night who reached out
to you was it Lorne does Lorne Michaels
person who made me laugh was Eddie
Murphy Eddie Murphy Hospital he came to
see you yeah no he did we both have the
same big business manager Mark Landsman
yes ml management yes and I was I was
you know medicated I was maybe out the
coma two weeks but I was still running
out and he said Eddie Murphy won't talk
to you I spoke to Eddie and he said some
stuff on the phone to me and I started
laughing
I put that really hard because I'm not
really all that hurt that is I got to
tell him I loved him for that when we
gave him the Mark Twain Award I told him
that direction
you do that I love Eddie by the way with
Eddie a you know he reached at you
that's a difficult phone call to make
because you don't know it from Eddie's
move you point you don't know whether to
joke with you so me to get better rested
take time off and just heal up right
take your time you the world will still
be there right look did you worry about
stuff like that did you sit there and
say is the world forgetting about me
what really affected me was when I was
in my wheelchair and when I first came
over in my wheelchair my daughter one of
my daughter she was a baby so when I
would pick up she stopped crying and I
started to take it personal then my wife
had to tell me Tracey she's a scared to
change the baby by trying she's 11 my 12
months old she's scared of the chair and
I understood but at 14 I got to see her
walk that night and I got it good on to
cheer myself I started walking on and
I'm my motivation for getting better I
ain't want to walk my wife down the
aisle with no cane right nobody want to
be in a cane
nobody won a cane it in other words you
had to teach yourself to walk and and
when you when you learn how to walk even
now when you doing stand-up of course
sometime rather than all this stuff you
need to sit down
sometimes on stage right because it's
what is it just painful to stand up
after why legs us yeah a little bit my
hip so she'll get back to the sex for a
second but as long as I'm funny lawns
the Lotus is a humor ain't hurting I'm
your son together you can't lose you
notice that I've said you can't lose
that's what I'm saying I mean listen to
the good so far all I'm hearing is
you're down 40 pounds you dick grew two
inches got harder more bulbous yellow
high school harder you like the book and
K you like the bionic man
but will you came in high school I'm
gonna hold out you can that's your shot
across the room dude I'm getting ready
when I'm getting ready to be run over if
I can get two more
my dick I will not get a do-over go from
one you have William felled a gazelle
William Tell go oh my god Olympic event
but here's one here's the thing
Tracey in a way I'm sure that the
doctors say to you listen don't [ __ ]
your wife you wait until you're a gent
at a certain point oh you had to tell me
they didn't have to tell you that I
always healing man how was it important
for me huh right tell me what we
together
how many weekly together Ryder Tracy not
again Morgan is a writer Tracy how many
weeks do you wait before you attempt sex
with your wife and now you know you're
gonna can't even remember man I was I
was at first I did really really really
just give it a fear the anxiety don't
focus on that when this big thing does
happen to you yeah and your arm and you
see cuts all over me from the glass
because I know guys who have had heart
attacks and then they go I'm afraid to
[ __ ] I'm afraid to eat I'm afraid to
you're afraid you're afraid everything's
gonna kill you are you kinda over that
part of what you always sort of freak
out on the highways sometime yeah when
I'm driving yes when I'm nice now right
job now yeah I bought the Ferrari yeah
but when I'm driving with someone and
someone else is driving our freaked out
are you buying some crazy [ __ ] now
because you do have a lot of money and
not that that's any consolation but you
driving the Ferrari I understand the
house crazy cars before I know but the
Ferrari and now you got a bigger house
right I mean you bought you you bought
on oh yeah how's that it you got you got
every well we are we we gutted it right
I gutted it from head to toe I just got
it now why do that last you but then you
got to move out while they fix it right
well I still got my the crib right and
so now this new place is crazy Robbie
yeah is yeah I got a bowling that Lena
if you got bullied all of that yeah are
you i you I got I got I got oh I would
start paper are you a are you able to a
bowl for my project me right yeah I'm
trying to sell it now these [ __ ]
what better break yeah I know about
project room [ __ ] come on man you do
that when you got right
more me but Tracy's ex-roommate good no
purple Tracy is that true when you got
the money you bought your project and
you said hey everyone got to pay rent to
me
yeah is that true and then no one will
pay yo one lady will like it cuz she's
not the T then she show you invested
show me your money in the projects well
I don't even know the [ __ ] Section eight
is [ __ ] privacy section me and people
coming out of money people tell me now
you're flying a lot of private uh what I
do is lot probably baby Wow who forced
air I'm no [ __ ] yeah are you able to
would you be able to go on I mean I know
you're on the on the tornado patients
will you be able to go on a tour bus or
would that freak you out too much
what would you be able to go on a tour
bus of what a tour bus what is that oh
that is so good no but seriously I mean
it wouldn't it be like a flashback to be
in a bus on tour doing that have you
owned a bus right right that's on a
different level
yeah I see so you're able to do that
I'll go to the store and get on a g4
would you be able to go to Walmart and
shop or you Jake [ __ ] that when I was in
that wheelchair still shop that warm oh
[ __ ]
you still get it right in here right
talk about Sun over everything with up a
goodie so talk about your William Tell
dick your dick now is big you're
recovering from a horrible accident that
everybody got now to the hook that left
foot will you self-conscious when you
first go big Tracy B you self-conscious
when you first went out in public after
the accident my god it's so big I hear
on it it does have hair on it well it's
got its own ecosystem but when you first
go out in public after the accident
after you're starting to recover are you
self-conscious like he like everyone
staring at my wife Mia me and my wife
yeah my wife cuz you just try be with my
wife wouldn't leave the house for months
but he's waiting doors near the may will
go to the supermarket a DIN doors five
months and then I just said I got angry
that's a [ __ ] that if I'm going to
Macy's to buy a shirt that I'm just
buying this shirt because all cameras
will concentrate but you ain't gonna
stop that you can't stop that
everybody got camera phone I can but I
I live right that's when I begin like
after seven eight ten months I started
to take my life back I need my life back
I got a live Tracy we got a normalised
oh my god Tracy you're at on too hard
for my wife and my daughter my son
yes I'm cuz I'm the king I'm the leader
if I'm acting abnormal [ __ ] what is
gonna do for the day they leave [ __ ]
right don't you buy an island by the way
I was thinking about it I don't I don't
[ __ ] around to come along Ali your own
Walmart on island yeah Tracy you're out
on tour right now was there a point
where you said [ __ ] it man I'm leaving
stand-up comedy I would think like I
thought about retirement forget stand-up
I thought about suicide man good oh I
was that damaged in the hospital man I
want to live I saw me if you wasn't
there you didn't think it was gonna come
arket ah I was struggling to say words
yeah I couldn't walk she let a wound on
my ankle in front of my left ankle man
that look like a horseshoe you could
pull my skin back and see my bone so
what's the motivated I bet it Tracy
what's the motivation to go out and do
stand-up cuz you're on tour now picking
up the pieces the motivation you're
gonna be performing at Carnegie Hall on
Saturday November Fest what was the
motive is what is the motivation like
let go back the motivation was a lot of
things it was seeing other stand-ups it
was knowing that I love stand up you do
love it family yeah was my wife mostly
man was my wife mostly I start out real
depressing I gain weight and then after
the settlement I was still depressed I
was still in that mindset and I'm laying
on the couch just laying on the [ __ ]
couch one day am I good and she's
looking at me like this and then one day
she just said why don't you get up and
go to the comedy club you big gut
[ __ ] that's good and what's
happened to you and what happened your
back oh my god
and what has darpinian grabbed the mic
but I remember what happened when you
were talking to Lauren Michaels in my
car one day oh yeah and I was on
phone and I got really emotional with
him he's talking I said long I'm gonna
come home and he said trade without
blinking he said doors always open I
trying week later I got October 17
October 17 when you went on shatter that
long I went home you know it was the
first time first time as the Emmys but
then I was the first time comedy he got
the immediate I remember I did that joke
Tina velak down Tina was in the front
row and I see Tina's it was in our heart
she started crying I said the joke she
was happy that the comedy was still
there right and then I went back and I
started doing it at Nora Michaels the
first time I ever touched the mic since
that night was the I want you to pitch
me that SNL did you get nominated for an
Emmy for that performance show coming
back on us right now
oh you're nominated yeah a lot of people
don't get hit by a car or truck and come
back yeah 14 months later what was it
like being in the 14 months later that
is amazing but listen hey let me finish
talking I was in at the pitch meeting
and this young cast all of them Keenen
legs all of them everybody the cast
whole cast was doing I know they were
doing it hardest pitch the best pitches
and they inspired me so much all men I'm
way after I left the pitch me and I went
to the cellar
and I grabbed the mic for the first time
but a very first time it was like a new
life and I did five minutes you mean
because you got so inspired by the pitch
man chatter night lot of cash but I
guess I'll always be indebted to that
cast for inspiring me to go back and be
funny one was and when I was doing the
show you know there's a dress show then
there's a live a live show so join the
dress y'all got in tomorrow ahead
because you have to have a dress up
somebody grabbed you and gold take your
trying set right and change your Kogi I
started to think that the audience was
looking at me like something's wrong
with me because this person is grabbing
me the audience I started getting my own
head like like you feel sorry for me
think I'm emailing this song so they
think I'm and then I told Lori Mike like
in between the dress and a I talk alone
me just me Lauren let's along I don't
know if I could do this man I don't know
I don't know cuz they think something
wrong me and Laura Michael simply said
Tracy they don't care about the funny
they just happy you hear in other words
they're staring at you have are you here
it's like seeing somebody who died and
came back kill that model are gonna see
new people stand up for me and I could
see him just clapping closing the eyes
like they were just really happy just
stops here nobody want to see no more
get die like that right crazy about
truck am I reading this right I think
you really now feel like people love you
I think your baby's proven to you
through the worst Center got away guard
got away do you think that in the way he
let you know you loved yet do you think
in a way you have my job to give it back
Tracy do you baby do you think in a way
you never really know that is not on
this level right do you think you could
bomb anymore in comedy I don't think so
that's a lotta [ __ ] us not what I
think about what do you think about I
think about giving a love back right and
and when you went up on stage for five
minutes after you know being with the
Saturday Night Live on innovation I'll
never forget right was welcome back
welcome back and and and but I'll never
forget it when I went to the Emmys that
night nobody knew I was there right
nobody
Lois Kane was my publicist back there
him and Dawn to executive producer did a
great job of keeping that secret for two
months right no wonder you were showing
up and when I went back there I came
back I was like on my way to the stage
everybody was looking at me like these
short ghosts didn't Lewis said Trey even
Lewis told my agent Steve shmoop
they were with me both of them were with
me and smooth man fact was smokey said
Tracy dig with Tina and I walked and she
had her back to me and said tape but she
turned around and lost it Wow and that's
a Tina I'll see you you got a consumers
give and go present at the end and
that's a Tina she just grabbed me start
crying Santino stop I'll see you after
you get off then I went over there and I
was with my men I was hosting at night I
mean you're so close you're so close to
Tina fami she's the ones gross 30 rock
and everything yes it's just nothing
about ya so when I went out and the
whole audience this was a shock because
I was there they didn't know I was gonna
be there have you been heckled since the
accident has anyone had an off only love
it's unbelievable the only love and now
you can be playing Carnegie Hall and you
gotta win the Emmy I mean you're gonna
have a hell of it no I'm gonna prepare a
stage it's not about that for me it's
just about I'm here talking to you Robin
and that's America overwhelmed me it's a
nervous happy yeah I can't believe him
I've grabbed y'all I haven't seen you in
two years bad because it was bad yeah it
was bad it was bad accident no I knew
that I liked Jimmy Mac is with me on his
couch right now and I just family I
don't saying your name I don't know them
the two sisters Jimmy Mac two sisters
came to see me at Caroline right and it
was all off it was a lot of hugs and I
dedicated that show to them right and I
totally brothers with me for the rest of
my life he whipped me
he's one of my strongest guardian angels
and I know it yeah what a horrible thing
to go through you don't know how is
there any blessing in it in the sense
that you go through something like that
and the lessons you learn from I mean I
our daughter my wife my sons
I love them I'm glad that I'm here for
them but guidance and I'm here I'm a
different person all right so you should
get back to the [ __ ] so when your
wife gets on top you put the she go are
you on your back long that was crazy
now first though she got on top of me by
late well I leg was still healing your
language hell you still in pieces you
couldn't go [ __ ] you couldn't do the
missionary position right off the bat
you can be can't move so you're on your
bag that took you that took about a year
right it was no it was a lot of it just
love the first honey a lot of eating the
first time does she initiate or do you
say listen it's not me to start cause me
you started and here you are you're
laying in bed your legs are broke you
can't talk it's all closed up dirty
[ __ ] right I'm a dirty animal
and when I want some [ __ ] I want some
[ __ ]
I know because there is time you hear
about all that [ __ ] when you first wake
up these she's supposed to come on rough
aggressive when you first wake up call
the lego man but when you brush but but
but Tracy when you first wake up from a
coma do you do you do you check to see
that it works I mean the seriously I
already been masturbation coax the
doctor that I need my dick man he of
course
imagine
come on doctor save me some more of your
dick with seven I said I'm going back in
this coma
my father tummy you come back when you
tell me when that might Jake right right
I lose my dick I gotta become a serial
killer huh Abby I'm snacks [ __ ]
man you gotta make a board you
completely heal but notably oh my do a
sizzle
Jacques burn and was your life shocked
that you were able at that point because
you weren't even walking yet I come off
right like she's like well Tracy you
could certainly learn a walk of you're
[ __ ] around
I like being pampered - all right who we
heard from since your recovery we've
heard from Lorne Michaels where Tina Fey
Alec Baldwin I assume all the cast of 30
Ron from our audience your dead
husband's did come out the toys been
very successful five six thousand people
you told me that dick Cape Cod 2229
Cape Cod yes I wasn't at it oh I just
the kid even write down a block
you [ __ ] can't afford no a seat
write down well Tracy's right he's out
on his picking up the pieces tour
appropriately dialing oh yeah
picking out the piece that's what
picking up the pieces we bout to shoot
the Netflix special and I'm told by big
data show did you have to create an
alarm did you have to create on the
winner of did you oh you come on if you
got your god new materials right there
is that true trance into it you always
say you go on life I've took with bad
things that happened to me and turned it
funny
have you thrown out your old act have
you is your ol dad gone and now all of a
sudden you just get up on stage what did
you do what is it energy but the energy
tracy morgan's through there is that
really true you mean to tell you you go
up on stage now you've had this accident
the whole world knows about it
you go up and create a whole new act
from nothing
am i facilitate as my duels that roll
with me right you write some material
come on man every I'm I'm I give my
audience more credit than that me right
hey buddy no I got hit by that Walmart
truck man I'm a just a boy not talking
about it right come on you guys aren't
you the therapy or kind of [ __ ] happened
with that and so you go out there and
you tell the story
what happened since the Akatsuki oh man
- it right cuz if you don't laugh you
gonna cry
right I'm just done crying yeah but
don't you think water my all right now
yeah but but oh is that that's not tears
Tracy don't you think in a way your act
now is probably stronger because not
only is there an anomaly but you also
have some no serious sometimes no
life-and-death kind of no is yeah I know
it is I tapped into something real
different that nobody in comedy cuz I'm
gonna go you are comedy how long is your
struggle good to the other side and came
back it's all kind of [ __ ] happening on
the other side right it's yeah I want to
[ __ ] lunch with [ __ ] Mary Magnus
one day this chick at me sitting next on
glory home are you now a firm believer
in the afterlife in other words you've
seen it for real and you know about this
life right but I bet you're letting
people and turn this into a sci-fi movie
at night
yeah I only know about this [ __ ] like
I'm sitting right here I was done and
Robin woman but I just aged [ __ ] up [ __ ]
I sound like a [ __ ] doing that man
she said I was floating around in it
nothing to pop come on baby smalls
waiting on me to go to control I you
want C to pack a big ain't seen no
[ __ ] about
I seen them all full of guy oh me money
I see that much Duke because it's show
public that you've made a ton of money
here are people hitting you up for money
a lot now I mean it's and white women
are looking at me now right
you have this right women soon huh how
much I'm who you think sponsored on the
Trump campaign I'm just returned he
supports dropping out support no [ __ ]
you're so rich now you have to support
Trump I don't [ __ ] with no politics man
God is my dude I keep my face and girl
you vote though and you will not know I
voted one time in my [ __ ] life
and as for Dave Dinkins we see how that
[ __ ] turns out it wasn't safe to come on
stream
father but to do water Bobby yeah with
me did President Obama do order water
boy de President Obama reach out to you
at all we've every killer yeah big big
big and did you kill me with it your
President Obama reach out to you at all
they said that he said he got on TV and
said on that's right Get Well Tracy yeah
and that's I'm not yeah I did a couple
of Correspondence Dimon's with them and
come far you've come in life with the
president United the press right he's
saying bro he heard about your bulbous
penis head came over why did you call
into our bulbous penis hell yeah
bob was what [ __ ] look like a mushroom
women love big dick hair they love big
balls and big dick oh they do but I
wouldn't know love some you Jays balls
the women I'm telling you only women
love you Jays balls hey somebody got
some big ball somebody told me that you
performed at Robert Kraft the owner of
the New England Patriots yeah you won't
like a [ __ ]
yeah ah come on you're doing a show for
room for a billionaire stuffy like bomb
I didn't even give a [ __ ] I was out
gonna go you need the CEO of the biggest
bank in the universe
JPMorgan sit right in front of me I
think I gave a [ __ ] about making him
laugh makes him laugh Tracy in other
words it was Robert Kraft 75th birthday
Ronnie graph is the dope yeah they hired
you hear me a comic [ __ ] I love
Rob Robert grotmann scram I love you get
get him a nice gift to did you hear the
sons and all he hired you to be the
Entertainer that night and you go out
and going up in front of billionaires I
got some big labs though did you
I just like saying bummed cuz that my
students on sale by shape right they're
not and I understand you Google don't
I'm hard like people I understand you
goofed on Tom Brady yeah I said I think
said he's a trump supporter yeah I said
you gotta hope your left tackle ain't
Mexican be able to get absolutely
so they laugh is
art as regular audiences or is it like
evidently not Tracy Tracy yeah you
[ __ ]
and ever I did made the bus cringe when
I said mother [ __ ] up from the jungle
I'm gonna talk my [ __ ] like I've been
talking about Tracy night changing Tracy
you come from the [ __ ] was dope because
they threw me in on a private jet we
landed in the airport and winamp up up
airplane clap crowd carrier no party a
night [ __ ] you mean you're in the hangar
and angle so you landed right at the
party right at the part they came back
in the cab out that night
no [ __ ] your auntie fire yeah I'm
working are working and get your movies
is that what before you get to the
movies the reason you're working so hard
is you want this comedy you know what
you're gonna take it on tour but you're
gonna film it and then you're gonna go
on HBO a what is it for for HBO a for
Netflix and they'll release your whole
comedy tour and once they do that you
got to come up with another new act
right it's all to the good
it's all good it's all to the good you
live your life have you shot the special
yet no when are you gonna shoot the
special October 28th I see a red big
theater why not shoot the Carnegie Hall
show you got a little you want to wait
Red Bank is all right so I'm still we
still put it together still put it
together yeah I was still living life
like my material is not something I just
write nice that's my experiences so
you're hotter than ever now what are
these two movies you're working on well
I just finished one with all that's
coming out in February with Ice Cube and
Charlie Day it's called fistfight
comment yeah comedy yeah very funny on
cinema and I just still want with Ed
Helms oh and Dido is the director that's
gonna be great
it's called the clappers I don't know
when that's gonna be another comedy then
I'm doing a big movie in February who's
that for oh no I don't know I forgot it
dust is it it's huge like a hundred
fifty million on a budget
oh no [ __ ] what is this movie about do
you know it's not like this cause is
animated Latta me all right are we going
to like Budapest for three months and
nice then I got another one called
[ __ ] [ __ ] we good gallon
intense gorgeous party that sounds like
something I would done no listen the
studio's who step into this new fun
yeah tray bag is back in listen I'm the
I'm the [ __ ] Six Million Dollar [ __ ]
man are you are you the hottest guy in
show business right now I'm like [ __ ]
right now are you the biggest guy in
Chaves obvious the Desmond Tutu of show
business will you do full frontal into -
will you do the - magical like I'm
related to Uncle Ben assertion forget
your momma I'm a magical name you're
like you're an Uncle Ben categorise
never stick is always fluffy will you
ever show an audience I can't wait to
deny you some but all huh will us a
party that's what he's subbu do - some
salad you're gonna eat a butthole -
gotcha you ain't never trust your wife
sound [ __ ] now you better go home and
stick your tongue - crack on and I don't
think she like do this oh [ __ ] - all is
forgiven do you think forgive me like a
mall [ __ ] did your wife ever say Traci
enough with sticking your tongue in my
ass [ __ ] you like a normal guy you eat
[ __ ] you ain't butter input that fault
Paul aren't you afraid that's a bridge
over troubled water but they say eating
vagina and butthole you can get disease
but you won't need a woman's ass after
she died not a ramp she's got to go in a
random one my might even taking my socks
off yeah my son's don't come off it
don't count because your penis is so big
did your wife ever say hey don't put it
all in
no she just say oh is it my stomach
really it's that big and do you ever do
you ever sit there and say to yourself
my vain one of my veins in size you all
I believe it I get it which I'm not a
penis like that are your balls big Tim
oh yeah a big white loo roll really
that's amazing
do you do you ever say to yourself like
oh my god you know now I mean God forbid
I mean it's so great by the way do shoot
a big load - do you have a bit like a
mall [ __ ] man you gotta get a mop
bucket really y'all get this mop god
damn it I'll for real on part one young
your lower back are you worried about
your success that with film with comedy
you don't or you do you worry it could
go to your head [ __ ] my marriage wiII
you stay faith you can all did that [ __ ]
20 years ago
will you stay take him on the vine even
in the game
you're not only one with two women in my
pocket go ahead why for my daughter
that's it I think about that seven
forgot more [ __ ] to most men never
gonna get right comedian you're in a
different clique about that [ __ ] right
I'm 47 going on 48 married I'm good
almost lost my life I think about that
dumb [ __ ]
good this is the new you this is not
Arrested Development over here now
you're focused no your focus always been
focus your focus I always been fun I
like it not like they were married to
men I saw him I believe I look at Acadia
birthday Shh
we can't he a birthday I was with Joan
Rivers yes chillin how do you keep you
all River sent me some stuff and Robin
Williams sent me some stuff for NAS room
downstairs I didn't want to tell you but
maybe now you're well enough Joan Rivers
died I know okay no all right hit me
hard
hey Don Rickles called me a lot of love
you darn Diddy yeah call me a lot you
know like I did call but nobody took my
call but I wasn't ready I guess I was a
big life ain't no lie in this house my
wife now I feel about you man you a
Robin I'm good time here yeah I miss
couch but we love you go really here man
coming in here was was different I think
seeing Tracy Morgan now it's more
important than ever
Robin was right if we'd had him seat
belts on me buddy died there are
possible
I saw that interview well I tried to
tell her because she was in the drama
trauma unit that knows she does nurses
Tommy thank God really we don't know if
you had to see bones in the police
report but when you drive your car now
do you believe support you don't know if
they had them on or not Tracy did now
when you drive the car you wear your
seat belt or I've always wore my
seatbelt right but it's possible in your
accident not wearing a seat belt might
have saved your life who knows I don't
know nobody was in that truck that night
right nobody I was in them remembers it
no nobody only God knows
only God knows I live with that every
day man I have to live my life now I got
my daughter's three I look at my life
and I go wow I'm fortunate don't said
I'm here Tamara friends my love to
miracle you're back yeah it's a miracle
you hug in the train wreck I don't think
you'll ever forget this week Speer
right no it no amount of time buddy
around me would my psychiatrist told me
the two biggest car accidents in history
was yours and Princess Diana's right
magic neck Wow yours and princess she
was a princess in that war do you do you
have any nightmares do you come so yeah
but I got so much with my daughter my
wife and some old food stuff I look for
right now how am I here how often you go
at psychiatrist how often you see a film
uh but dr. Feinberg lives right there
right let's see my psychiatrist like
once a week once a month at least right
yeah you got it you got it they want to
stay with a they stay on top of me my
kidney doctor right they all stay on top
of me
don't stay on top of this yeah are you
surprised by someone who didn't reach
out have there been people who did not
reach out to you after your accident
that you feel should have no I don't
know wait you don't feel that way that's
not the way I think right that's not the
way I think I just I told you years ago
I something appreciate me right I'm
quite sure people know don't wish I'll
die now maybe they're all I don't know
but most people don't come across in
life every day I'm really happy to see
me they really I'm patient with them a
petition to take pitches you know I do
with my life man did you always done
that before the accident I love my fans
I love them you know I take I'm patient
with them I'll take a picture with you
and heartbeat you know what I was
thinking nothing you ever see these
people go into a coma and they come out
they could speak a whole nother language
or they speak with an accent [ __ ] like
nobody should happens man I came out I
feel like my stand-up went to the next
level me write this [ __ ] I'm thinking
about this [ __ ] I'm coming up with on
stage I see that today I think you're
more I don't know there's something
different with you I don't know man I
don't know what would you your eyes see
me I see something I just feel different
did you bury any old feuds after an
accident like that did you say [ __ ] it
man you know what like to shoot foster
feuding
[ __ ] he's still angry
how many people are you money I can [ __ ]
I'm gonna collect
I'm the river which a lot of people were
drinking now Tracy I'm gonna recommend
that people go out and see this tour
picking up the pieces this is it you
know what man I feel great to be
nominated for this Emmy man you gotta
win it I feel great to be nominated for
the Emmy and I'm in good company Bob
Newhart go ahead Larry David go ahead
people man you beat these guys though
that's what it's about that for me man
runner-up is not good enough you gotta
win this one and will you write a speech
will you write a speech you will and who
will be of course beside myself who will
you thank in that speech seriously I'm
just gonna say at the end man this one
is for you Jimmy Mac know you're gonna
do it you're gonna you already know what
you're gonna see you Jimmy Mac yeah no I
don't know what i'ma say I get the eye
but that's the spirit I just know Jimmy
I just know my dude man I miss him
can I say something to you he was a good
dude kind how'd you meet her warm
where'd you meet who the first person
ever met show business what was he doing
is running the workshop she went and
took a comedy workshop he was the first
one who came with the keys open the
doors out Jimmy Mac or something Tracy
Morgan and he doesn't want to took me
around the neighborhood to all the
comedy clubs and smile oh man I ain't
funny funny in other words he took you
to eat courage deal Jimmy Mack was the
guy who encouraged you right Tracy in
other words how old were you at that
point
Oh 21 21 and most people didn't believe
in you right he did yeah dad did yeah
but some people didn't think you were
funny or a guy from your neighborhood
could make it right because guys in your
neighborhood don't don't make it they
don't make it and a guy like Jimmy Mack
said you could make I'm living proof and
from inspiration of those now the father
and I think that's what it is
I spy a lot of people me and Jimmy was
genuinely hanging by the truck like that
and live and all that do you care - and
Jimmy was genuinely happy for you in
other words some guys who we care about
all the others a chelate he just
happened he was as happy down funny all
the little do
we're gonna shave it and tickle them but
we came off on stage it just tickles it
think about all the people in this world
who ignore you you know I had so many
teachers who never even paid me any
attention and you know now I'm famous
okay but it's okay yeah it's fine
but but Jimmy Mack said all right I see
something yeah yeah that was Jim yeah
though Jim he took me in face man my
father another comedian fellow comedian
man face man um he took us on his way
that's great but then again you know
before I met Jim I put my pops was a
cool dude from Vietnam being a bronze
rolling and smoking this joint playing
the bongos that night with deployed week
ahead and he was one of those do when
you saw your dad in heaven uh why was he
wearing a green suit theater I'm is he
an elder did he wear a green suit in
life don't know was that his thing I
don't know I think it was his I may have
been in and out maybe the medication I
don't know did you get your big [ __ ]
from him did you inherit that from him
our dicks aside is he doing chocolate
yeah dimples yes and this was what he
did for no reason awesome Oh G my dad I
didn't hurt his butt my dad a big dick
we hazard a dick but uh come on don't
get at all dude dude do you [ __ ] dude
this big Claymore make it [ __ ] out
[ __ ] walk come on you're not that
[ __ ] clown all that and I mean as did
he have no self-esteem I'd be so much
more clever confidence in your stay was
through the roof huh
but I gotta say this though man what was
I gonna say that's it the act of it
Sukie forget what you gotta say just
blame the accident all right listen to
me you're the best and I love that you
hear I didn't know when I'd see you
again I don't know if I'd see you again
I wasn't gonna bug you and say come in
it was one of the things we talked about
when I came home like after the 40th huh
I told my I'm gonna go I'm gonna go on
Howard cuz I will watch the shows that
we did yeah just to see what my funny
was how well you was you've always been
funny on this show but I couldn't watch
it for this show right here I just
wanted to come and kick it I know this
was a different show ma'am I know that
happened and we was gonna rap about it
yeah yeah how can you not I mean for
God's sakes
Tracey's out there now
is going to win the Emmy I predict he
will win the Emmy which is I think in
september/october the Emmys right that's
right and you gotta go right you're
gonna go and my wife will go you will go
but what she where will she wear a titty
dresses nah I hope why not why not
perceive any beautiful girl men are feel
fortunate ours like yeah I feel Maddie
one with me fortunate we met your
wedding your how was i I didn't invite
anyone from chauvelin's to the wedding I
wanted to be a real wedding you know a
single now who Chris Rock we have art my
man I see Brock all the time at the
cellar
he's my man yeah but yeah my man wearing
red sneakers which I'm the light rays
because he won't get young girls girls
like colors when she died like Chris
Rock is my heart he came to the house he
did went when top 5 when he did before
it came in the movie did it yeah and
once he came and brought me to film oh
wow then no one's gonna be ready to go
and came to my house early in the
moonlight Levin your trade Bhoomi sat
down he kicked Enoch 8 hours people came
and saw me Robert Carlock kids and house
I would have come they don't like me my
goal is right there I know I mean I miss
Michael my first shots an L yeah you
know I love Robert yeah it's my friend
do you sit down with Chris Rock you say
listen don't go to [ __ ] crazy with
being now I gotta say that the rock rock
too smart for that he knows Rock tons of
glow man smiley he's my old gene he's
smart
yep the smart man smarter than that but
a little advice wouldn't hurt right now
I well I don't want to overstep my
bounds on my do not time I said you know
you know you good yeah don't go I and go
crazy do you think you'll become an
inspirational speaker there's that in
your future do you think you might need
go to like hospital yeah you do you
think you might end up as if I do
anything in the beauty of my sense of
humor
oh that's the gift he gave me alright I
tell people interviews all the time
Robin they want to talk more material so
don't it's like Bruce Lee said it into
the dragon ah it's like a finger
pointing away to the moon
don't focus on a finger are you gonna
miss all that heavenly glory that like a
heavenly glory what's important to me is
the funny from Hollister Hollywood but
was he good we're not gonna talk about
we talking about was he funny did you
lie
funny is where I thank God that's the
gif he gave me with the funny
thank God the funny is here in other one
you're not going back to the series
going to funny Morgan Tracy Morgan is
back he has William Tell dick anyone
know he's got comedy and a huge [ __ ] I
grew up with like his hot pick it up
when it's cold believe me and if anyone
can put two inches on my dick I'll pay
them I'm telling you that so look Tracy
Morgan you're out there picking up the
pieces door that's gonna be happening
Carnegie Hall Saturday November 5th
every one second top door Carnegie what
about tobacco this Tracy that's a
badness I'm much more mature right you
know why when I love coming on this show
but I get to be so immature talk about
[ __ ] knowledge now what time kids
talking my [ __ ] all day long what I
grown ass man I like to talk more about
money deep my dad got to be on the
low-low you're damn right a low low ten
Wayne said that they gave me 95 million
dollars over five years is that a lot of
money that's a lot of money
court nuttin is no taxes come out no
like child support can't even [ __ ] Wow
yeah it's not right nine come out you
get all of it and your agent don't get
any of that come at a businessman
accident that's right the lawyers fee
when I read 95 million and I know Damon
Wayans don't know damn he doesn't [ __ ]
you know what's in my pocket
if that was true Walmart would assume
that [ __ ] out of me cuz my confident you
write all the people that notice in my
pocket is in my bag about you girls
that's it you told your wife I'm going
to my grave with that is it smart to
tell your wife what you got from all she
was in on and she was dead but you know
the UH where's she going I'm gonna get
married again
so the 95 million when we read 95
million that's cuz some guy just picked
that out of the air yeah they don't know
that [ __ ] that that statement Wayne
nobody knows what I got except for me
my business manager and my lawyer but
why doing Ferraris you bought projects
and your egg you're like a foot accident
though but you're flying private all the
time that's all good that's all good
it's all good
are you are you investing this money
that you got whatever the amount is are
you do what are you doing with it I got
somebody honest
trees no come on what are you doing jump
or pickup what are you doing are chillin
are you I'm chillin I'll discuss that
people man you know what you ought to do
grow a beard and get one of these farms
like give them how are you it come bushy
beard and all my family it's a couple of
movies I don't know blink twice if it's
over 100 million look at you not the
Lincoln what time what time tonight
you're gonna be eating ass go ahead you
said you got you wanted 10 or 11 I'm
gonna go to the property
could you imagine all the bosses I got
in my new mansion looks like boys and
girls high school football field
describe it to me boys and girls but
you're not gonna blow the money you
didn't mean some of the money in the I'm
good with money man I don't care what
people say I'm good what do people say
ain't good I won't throw the money cuz I
got a call well they see the Ferrari
wait they hear about the private jets
they hear about the renovation all right
would you want to make sure you're doing
good unbelievable
what's the backyard look like what you
got back there you got a baseball field
I just move my pool from one side so it
up just like that they know about having
equipment back there man in other words
you move the pool just to [ __ ] move
it I mean it is no time for that comes
from the ceiling uh-huh why move the
pool that's the last thing you sit on my
toilet and take a [ __ ] you could warm
your feet why move the pool cuz I just
wanted to move it just for the hell of
it right you doing hey listen I gave my
dorritos truck man come on because in a
snap you struck and this ain't no
above-ground pool Walgreens are you
saying you say in this pool is in the
ground I gotta see this you got one in
the house and went upstairs and you got
serving some stuff going on my personal
service I can make Mogu cheese sir
you're not looking for anything for the
hood man I'll put the project's I go no
forget that to troubleshoot bathroom I
heard you're so rich now that you're
gonna move to pull back to the old
location you've moved it and ain't gonna
keep wound every
do what you wanna do put it like this to
do the court directly my neighbor to
work Greg his house is 38 million really
do I listen I live in Alpine oh oh I had
fun baby I'm surprised you didn't even
move right the [ __ ] out so they want to
right yeah you know he does fun you know
those big oil rigs in this deep sea yeah
they get all he builds them he builds
the oil rig he owns the company
he thought Payton is a [ __ ] for
the project's the right deck so this is
justice
do you have an elevator in yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] you had a bowling alley yeah the
bats will call that basketball coming up
big movie theater I leave my house never
oh [ __ ] I'm chilling you got damage all
for my family yeah
I need his new pair of sneakers of 1550
on into my pocket a new physics that's
all any blockage there I showed my
brothers gotta see you guys in my
neighborhood I'm gonna call the cops on
you my [ __ ] song cuz you got no
business here god damn it to the cops
hassle you could they say update let me
not they know it's you know you made me
very large right right I want listen to
this this was highly anticipated you're
right
people pulled over on the shoulders go
what the [ __ ] are they talking about
Morgan and started robbing oh [ __ ] man
Google games gonna be late you know me
people got 500 jobs listing themselves
on [ __ ] around on the show so no one's
ever gonna know him but solicits [ __ ]
name I don't know no one's gonna know I
got the big new JJ do you ever think
about that dude look at this new hat you
imagine the [ __ ] running through this
house no if you oh my goodness how dogs
are so domain but sometimes don't you
look at that housing go man look at the
oh no the pool no 70 old Tracy where did
that tennis court do Tracy what it did
that do you wear like 47 year old Tracy
don't do that cuz I'm only playing
semi-pro now do you get dressed up you
get dressed up and everything now Peter
lubbers or something like that you could
be eating an aspirin I'm still eating
Chinese food from the hood
nice
chickens and fried rice that's how I get
down
mm-hmm that's just uh but I cut my carbs
now so I'll he right here look like
right are you working out - yeah work
out I leave my car y'all do I'm doing it
right this time I got a second chance
time is excite are you sectional me I'm
a sex symbol bet my daughter's three
years off trying to be here for him yeah
she play now she running me around for
girls won't they know there's any good I
gotta play my daughter but doesn't she
need some black friends I mean in that
whitey neighborhood isn't there just too
many white people for her to find her
identity no problem and people people
with me on my vein gonna raise it up way
writing black right he's not gonna raise
our daughter that way with you worry you
don't worry right right my wife is
biracial but I don't see that I don't
see my wife right right it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter what is she
supposed to come out as she's supposed
to have an accent if she wearing Balmain
jeans my mother now name is Chrissy wall
over why didn't you and I love my
mother-in-law that's mine when I see my
mother lawn my wife and my daughter
standing right there I tell my [ __ ]
around me all that belong to me right
all that belong to me so if you ain't
willing to lose a toe or finger walk
away I'm going all out for mine
right I'm going all out for months
because your wife is Jamaican I'm
looking for garbage can I'm a cracker
Heineken bottle and almost got you like
a drought if you're if your wife is
wrong if your wife your wife is very
beautiful do you worry about other men
hitting on her my confidence is to
alchemor well you don't try it you know
a woman get you man she hopes mother if
she looks at other guy you just go wall
boy oh boy you don't want to do it no
one's doing did you sign did you sign a
prenup
yeah I mean I wanted to that okay maybe
yes you know I'm gonna go all right
don't tell me the money you got now you
can't even be touched by alimony or
anything that is your money you get
awarded money in court mm-hmm come out
I've never been wrong a good man can't
touch you well sure you robotically
can't touch you nobody listen I don't
care about none that stuff all we was
doing that night was
we were on our way home from that's
right you just coming home from work
it's crazy that's all an act but none
today no no you weren't looking for
trouble to make you upset anyone you
upset anyone make our fans have said I
want my wife being upset like I said has
the day what none of that crazy though
has the truck driver ever tried to
apologize to you personally I don't know
no you don't know no I'd stay away from
that it's all in the state's hands now I
see actually you know I'm saying it's
all in the state's hands
that's not your mine that for me when it
was back there I live my life now you
got to buy Balmain jeans with all your
money what's that supposed to the
builders of the Burcham $2,500 jeans I'm
Hina your comedy straight Levi's leo my
leg a detail on my feet you sitting out
at the baby box
you never see me come in with the
Michael Jackson Captain Crunch jacket
you never see none of that Robin people
must be trying to say tre come here
looking crazy yeah I got my little
bracelet in that [ __ ] that's it
I'll keep my money on the loan but
thanks I got we're not going on right
you got me County $5,000 jeans for you
how do you know that will I would say a
koala but I stayed in the village cuz I
want people to vote the bill oh I think
you lie to the village I bet you a lot
of people try to like now milk you for
money you know what I mean they see you
in there they're all theirs together got
my game face on when you did the
construction I get how Sheree face when
you did the construction on your ass and
they try to jack up the price on you now
no no everybody's cool everybody was
cool well that's the best thing I've
everybody's cool I got people around me
mark Landsman my man Lewis okay I got
people around me my team take care of me
man what's that bracelet worth that gold
bracelet you're wearing yeah that looks
expenses ninety thousand ninety thousand
so what about that necklace this is my
number one dad yeah you can see none or
me you better you better pop you Lance
that's all it is security person I got
my go opulence
no something wrong with that
no I feel it Tracy I predict you will
win the I never seen I was starting to
[ __ ] Airport I know you got a jet -
what jet hey I don't go anywhere don't
eat a bar every day I don't go any
attention home got a Teterboro when you
are go out y'all go to Teterboro this is
about you not me
alright look Tracy Morgan see how you
switch it off Tracy you lived and that's
all I give a [ __ ] about thank you I love
you I love you I really truly do I'm so
goddamn happy you are alive and doing
well and you got your vision back you
got your health back you're walking
you're talking and you're doing comedy
you're up for an Emmy
you done 600 movies and now picking up
the pieces tor who would have thought
two years ago you'd be on any tour but
here you are god bless you my friend and
I really do I just appreciate you so
much and I'm glad I got to say that to
you today because I've been waiting to
say it for two years and you know I know
I'm not at the house with Eddie Murphy
and Chris Rock it doesn't take you cold
I know you don't take my calls but then
I was I was praying for you and I don't
pray for many people and I prayed for
you because I love you and I care about
you and I'm happy you back I really mean
it you're here and you're alive and
thank you for being here today I know
it's a lot you talked about a lot a lot
of this stuff is hard to talk about I
know so I appreciate you doing that
thank you
a lovely palette I love you Robbie uh
you made us laugh and you made us crazy
I blow you if your dick wasn't so big -
big [ __ ] jaw fried your jaw and Tracy
for tickets and info on all the Tracy's
tour dates you go to Tracy Morgan calm
you know I like to sell to all the fans
out there I love you and for the Mack
family McMahon family I love you guys
too and I love all the guys Jeff and
Audie and Howard standing that were in
the car and Ty and I love all you guys
thank you I love my ferrets thanks Tracy
thank you Howard Stern